bonjour monsieur picard merci d'être en
direct avec nous alors la chine détrône
donc les etats-unis comme premier
partenaire commercial de l'europe
eh bien oui c'était était attendu lors
des premiers publication qui fit coupole
17 ans je l'annonçais donc on a à peu
près dans les années qui était prévu
puisqu'en fait la politique chine est
également planifiée à came on sait
maintenant où elle va dans tous les
domaines
il suffit de lire les rapports doublé en
français gauche donc oui c'est pas
étonnant d'autant plus que ce grand pays
a la particularité d'étudier les crises
et d'essayer de gérer qui répondront
eux-mêmes avant qu'elle n'arrive pas un
peu de la prévention se voulait donc on
l'a vu pour la crise de 2007 2008 la
chine a su anticiper et réinvestir il
après la crise sanitaire qui est bien
évidemment pas j'ai pas de son fait d'un
virus là aussi la chine s'y est préparée
elle a répondu je dirais avec
pragmatisme
à la crise sanitaire est aujourd'hui
bien évidemment elle est aussi ça va
aller un peu plus vite mais de toute
façon la chine est lancée aujourd'hui
c'est pour ça que l'on voit jeu j'avais
beaucoup de dire et de propos anti
chinois c'est dans la presse occidentale
je dirais à ces gens d'aller visiter la
chine pour eux ne s'en rend compte qu'il
s'agit bien de la vérité oui aujourd'hui
est en train de devenir
où va le devenir rapidement la première
puissance mondiale
mais pas uniquement au niveau économie
également dans de nombreux domaines tels
que de l'innovation de l'intelligence
artificielle et donc c'est vraiment une
très grande nation moderne qu'il
faudrait aujourd'hui devant nous oui
alors comment la cie justement a réussi
à sortir de la crise économique et de la
crise économique post crise sanitaire
alors que certains pays européens la
france par exemple est encore en plein
dedans
vous savez que quand les chinois nous
avons prévu par exemple que la crise
sanitaire arriver chez nous on n'a
pratiquement rien fait on les apatrides
et témoin de cette lubie janvier je
crois on n'a pas pris les dispositions
qui nous permettraient de je dirais 2
c'est pas facile j'en conviens au regard
de cette crise sanitaire donc et ensuite
les chinois ont eu également des dix ans
des difficultés dérives que les crises
ils ont des cellules je dirais comme ça
pour parler comment dire non pas
rapidement mais pour schématiser ils ont
donc des étudiants des experts qui
travaillent sur le le conduire le le
renouveau unique
mais tout cela s'inscrit aussi dans une
politique cohérente de réformes drew
politique cohérente de développement
d'innovation pour encourager le
développement durable donc ciblé avec la
chine elle est sur les rails depuis de
nombreuses années et si elle ne veut pas
devenir une première puissance pour dire
qu'elle a une première puissance la
chine souhaite effectivement devenir ou
dans de nombreux domaines
une nation exemplaire donc tout cela ça
fait partie d'un des plans des plans
quinquennaux des réformes
et là effectivement correct pourra se
dire et des promesses ont été faites
mais dix sont tenus alors que chez nous
en occident change très très loin de
politique en chine dont les choses ont
bien provoquer alors deux enfants parce
que la chine devient le premier
partenaire commercial de l'europe mais
détrône par la même occasion les états
unis nouvelles ce qui ne va pas
forcément plaire à washington oui
écouter et union janot p ouachi qua non
pour que projet il s'est en fait une
catastrophe pour les baies de vie oui
bon qu'ils vont devoir céder leur place
il ya un petit peu logique et y jusqu'à
présent considéré qu'ils étaient les
seuls maîtres du monde avec une jiren de
philosophie de deux pionniers absolument
extraordinaire oui en même temps une
volonté de gouverner le monde à leur
manière
donc là aujourd'hui on va avoir un monde
beaucoup plus multilatéraliste chimie
pas typique souhaite une gouvernance
internationale dans de nobles et on va
voir la raison de dire pourquoi on voit
toute la mer de chine
on voit toutes sortes de fausses
nouvelles ou
deux choses qui t'en dit contre la chine
pour essayer d'installer de sellières ce
pays surtout avec l'administration de
neuf jeunes et enfin tête pour essayer
de casser cet élan de la chine du picard
suis désolé on a des petits problèmes de
liaison fouquet remercie d'avoir répondu
à nos questions je rappelle que vous
êtes géopolitologue et spécialiste de la
chaîne merci à vous